hey what's up guys my name is Ayana and
welcome to episode 97 of game
programming okay so last time we talked
about how to remove the player faster or
any entity really how to move any entity
faster than normal and still be precise
with our collision because of course if
we move the if we move an entity faster
then it can actually calculate collision
is and we advance it by more pixels than
there is solid object then and then
we'll skip over the solid object and
that's obviously a bad thing so we
talked about that and we implemented an
awesome method here now today we're
gonna talk about a completely different
method okay and that's gonna be how to
not only let us go faster because what
is what this essentially does is it
allows us to move more than one more
than one pixel I guess okay but the
limitation of this is it has to be an
integer because there's a full loop okay
and there's this whole deal about that
okay and the other thing is so what this
does not let us do is two simple things
it only lets us pick speeds such as 1 2
3 4 5 etc right that is right oops
right that's what it lets us do okay now
what it doesn't let us do now it should
probably go it allows what it does not
let us do is something like 0.4 0.6 1.4
you know 5.5 etc okay it doesn't allow
us to do that now that's a bad thing
because we want we might want to be able
to move the player at 1.4 pixels you
know per update or you know or less than
one if we want something to move slower
than one we might want to go to zero
point zero point four something
something like that okay something
ridiculous like that for example so how
do we do that well it's very simple
really the thing that you have to
realize first of all is there aren't
there is no such thing as less than one
pixel that does not exist your computer
screen is made out of pixels any display
is okay not any display in the world but
the probable display that you can replay
this on and the way that we're
programming this is to deal with pixels
pixels are integers get that into your
head right now pixels are integers
there's no such thing as zero point four
pixels that does not exist because a
pixel is either one or zero okay okay
that pixel either exists or it doesn't a
pixel is one by one pixel wide it cannot
be sorry one by one pixel so one wide
one pixel wide and one pixel high it's a
square okay there's no such thing as
having one point four pixels okay
you either have one pixel or you have
two pixels you don't have one point for
that being said that being said there's
there is obviously a difference between
moving 1.4 pixels and moving 2 pixels or
one pixel if we move one pixel to the
right sorry this is getting a bit in
depth but I feel like I should explain
this if we're moving one pixel to the
right yeah then we've you know landed on
let's just say one zero okay if we move
another pixel right we've landed on to
zero now if we move two pixels right
then we've landed on two zero four eight
zero zero if we move another two pixels
right we've landed on four zero right
however if we choose to move one point
four pixels right first of all we've
landed on one we round down one zero and
if we move another one point four pixels
right then what is that
that's three zero and that's now
accessible to us whereas it wasn't
through this so what this allows us to
do is really take control of the
precision of how we do this thing and
the reason this is one point four and
one point four and this isn't a round
down to two is because we still store
the position as a double that's the
other major difference right now we're
storing the player's position and the
any entities position as an integer in x
and y which means it can only be values
like one two three but the idea that
what what of what we want to do is store
our entities positions as a double okay
and then we can have things like 1.4 so
double x equals 1.4 for example but when
it comes to rendering of course we'll
cast it back to an int and it will go
down to one okay because will cost X to
an integer which of course will equal
one in this case because it's rounding
down in fact it illegal no they called
one and an ek
because um that's how that's what does a
chart it chops off the remainder okay so
what we've basically enabled us our
selves to do here is is create a way to
really control the precision okay so the
plate that the entities locations will
now be stored only as a double which
means that it will be precise no matter
what but then when it comes time to
render it will just cast it to an
integer so that's how that's gonna work
okay that's the first thing when he's
doing then we'll talk about slowly
moving so if we go back into entity
dodge over here we've got our protected
int x and y we're gonna change that to a
double that's gonna create so many
errors here first of all we should deal
with this these get X and get Y they are
supposed to return integers no longer so
they're going to return doubles now okay
because x and y is a double so public
double get x and public don't get why
this arrow here render sprite it it
accepts two integers we're giving it two
doubles so what we need to do here is
actually convert into an integer now
depending on how you want to do things
you might want to actually round it up
using math dot seal or something along
that along those lines but i'm going to
simply cause it to an integer like that
at all essentially round it down okay
fantastic
if we go back into our chaser we also
have issues in every rendering class
because random mob is now a thing so we
want to go into X we actually want to
probably subtract it first and then cost
it to an integer it won't matter too
much actually one matter at all because
they are integers but let's do it that
way just in case just in case we run
into problems so shoot for example I
think shoot is yeah it's just this thing
so yeah was a projectile so we don't
really actually I think what are these
oh these are already doubles okay that's
weird why do we uh why don't we cost of
why do we have in those integers that
shouldn't be like that an X origin and Y
origin these are integers let's make
them all doubles since we're dealing
with precision now you can make them
floats as well if you want but there's
really no need float so just a touch
precise usually not enough to matter but
doubles are usually the way to go
so this shoes method takes two doubles
now instead of integers and wizard
projectile also take three doubles and
set of integers
okay so fixing up this stuff we get more
ours as well this is like a little fight
here make sure that you cast everything
to an a to show essentially the way that
you guys want to do this is we have this
little problem this thing over here
you wanna go through all these and fix
them up okay I'm doing in front of you
but I imagine it will be very you know
not really fun to watch me correct every
all the stuff in all these different
classes and try and follow along okay
back in our game da Java class we have
black get X and stuff like that so X
scroll and Y scroll values again you
know level dot Randa what I'm gonna do
here is I'm actually gonna cast it to
ian's over here and it keep these babies
as double so they get calculated as
precisely as possible what else do we
have here so random mob again it means
int okay I'll get entities so we'll go
ahead and that'll be fine as an integer
that won't be a problem okay because
that's like getting radius stuff so I'll
just paste integer here a bunch of times
and we've that's it we've solved all
that power problems let's just check
that the game still runs and as you can
see it does great so that didn't take
too long luckily now now that we've done
that let me just close everything here
and only our cannot mob cuz that's all
we need Mamdouh Java here now that we've
done all that let's talk about how we
can actually improve this this method
here and actually get it to use doubles
and we've already got doubles up here
which is which is wonderful so how do we
do this well first thing I'm gonna do
and you guys might think this is weird
or something but I'm actually gonna just
first of all move these out here and
actually we're well might as well move
this guy out as well let me just whoops
by the way I get this question a lot I
use I'm using alt so I'm holding down
alt and then I'm using the up and down
arrow keys and that'll actually just
move the selected piece of code even if
it's just one line okay
so pro tip right over there okay so I'm
actually just getting rid of these for
loops completely okay so what I've done
now is I've brought it back to this meta
basic method which is what it is now
this is to note as well that this is
still a BS so what's that what this is
calculating again is just whether it's
positive or negative and then it's
returning a 1 if it's positive and if
it's negative it's returning a negative
1 so what we want to do now is calculate
this very precisely so what we want to
hit off is while XA and it's just 4 X is
greater than 0 okay so while X a is
greater than 0 we want to basically move
the player because if it's oh sorry by
player and really mean entity because
any entity or any mob rather any mob of
course has access to this move method so
we want to move the mob as long as there
is still something left to move right so
while while XA is less than is greater
than while X a is greater than 0 we
still have more we still have a distance
to move that mob so the first thing we
want to calculate is whether we actually
have more than one kind of like integer
so what I mean by that is essentially we
want to calculate if if X a is greater
than 1 okay so if X a is greater than 1
and really the the idea is it's pretty
much XA minus 1 is greater than 0 okay
but that I'll give you the same result
so basically we want to check if we
subtract 1 from XA will it still be
greater than 0 now the reason we're
checking for this is because think of it
this way right if um if you if you want
to move because what what we had going
on with the for loop and with this ABS
thing is we only move right we only move
the player and again I'm in mob we only
move the mob by a maximum of one value
right
we were only move the mob by a maximum
of one pixel per update that way we know
that our collision will work so what we
want to do here is we want to say that
if let's just say if if X a happened to
be one point four
that's greater than one which means that
we can actually subtract one so we can
move the ball we can move the mob one
pixel which will now make it 0.4 if we
subtract it okay and now we go again
right because it's a while loop we go
back to the top and we say okay X is
still greater than zero zero point four
is XA greater than one right
so if we subtract one from this would be
greater than zero because we don't we
definitely don't want to subtract it and
then be like oh crap we're at negative
zero point six we shouldn't have moved
that far we want to be able to make sure
that we are they subtract what's needed
and then if it isn't then we can deal
with that okay because it's less than
one so what which I can here again is
whether we can subtract 1 from X a and
it will still be greater than zero so if
we can do that then we simply move the
player or so I remove the entity move
the mob so I keep freaking screwing that
up I'm sorry we we move the mob by one
okay by either one or negative one again
depending on what our XA is like now
here's the tricky part that's actually
really easy but we've added this dot XA
and we've done all that good stuff now
what we need to do is essentially go XA
minus - whoo so we want to subtract 1
from X but here's the issue and this
really isn't a big issue but here's the
issue XA can sometimes be negative so if
we're going and this is this is whether
this is where the greater than zero
comes in as well which we'll talk about
in a minute
but this is where this comes in okay we
have this we have this problem where if
XA let's just say XA is I'm good for
what we're doing here is we're just
making a negative 5 that's making it
even more what we want to be doing is
getting it closer to zero now in this
case we could actually do something like
let's just subtract a BS XA so that
we'll just subtract 1 so in other words
if if XA is positive it will subtract 1
if X a is negative it will subtract
negative 1 which will actually add 1 ok
and we we could also do let me think
because we have to solve this somehow
right we have this issue here that we
want to solve because XA is not always
you know
it's sometimes it could be less than
zero sometimes it could be greater than
zero and we want to kind of adjust for
that so the obvious answer here really
is going to be to just make sure that we
go and check if it doesn't equal zero
because zero is the position we want it
to be at no matter what because zero
means that there's no pixels left to
move them the anticipate so that's what
we're doing
okay so again just to go through this so
the idea with this then is pretty much
to check if it's physican to zero so
what we want to do then is of course I
showed you the other way just before
well what we did was we subtracted 1 and
then we checked if it was greater than
zero so what we can do is we can um
actually instead of subtracting one we
can actually subtract a BS XA okay and
again that'll be positive ones positive
and we can check if if that actually is
greater than zero or not so then the
idea here really is to basically say
okay well no matter if it's negative or
positive how can I check if it's you
know if there's value still to be added
and the way that we can do that is by
simply calling maths or ABS which will
make this positive no matter what and
then we can check if it's greater than
one
okay so scenario number one we have
negative one point four is it is it
greater than one well first of all mass
of ABS will make this positive one point
four and then it'll be like is one point
four greater than one well yes we'll
continue scenario two it's positive one
point four mouth OBS we'll make it
positive one point four and then is one
point forward in one yes okay so that
satisfies all of our scenarios here and
it's getting a bit complicated but
that's just don't know the nature of
this so that's that's actually it okay
that is it for if it's greater than one
now if it's not greater than one then
that's actually the really easy part
because what that means is first of all
that we're actually greater than one so
there's actually no like a minimum
collision we can check so what we need
to do is copy and paste this collision
method but instead of going this odd X
plus equals abs we simply plus equals XA
okay and the reason is we know that this
is less than zero sorry we know that
this is less than one okay well the
place the absolute of it is less than
one which means that we can check for
one
you know just to be vital here make sure
that actually we're using the wrong abs
in aren't we we should be using um X
over here because we're just evaluating
accent so make sure that you are make
sure that you fix that up otherwise
you'll uh although you'll get some
problems so abs should be of course on
XA all right cool
where's our extra bracket yeah I think
it's in there okay wonderful
so that's how that works and of course
since we have done this and this will
give us 0 we set X equal to 0 okay kind
of long process now we didn't do the
same thing for y so while Y a doesn't
equal 0 this is the easy father which
substitute values here so this what why
why not sorry not here okay not
everywhere over here we want to hit up Y
a - equals ABS Y a collision will fix
out a minute but this should be Y a this
should be Y a and that looks pretty good
so now let's fix up collision so we'll
remove ABS from here post it over here
abs and okay maybe I says now reminded
me of that braking system automated
braking system not sure what's called
advanced braking system maybe anyway
here we have the completed thing so
hopefully this works right I haven't
actually tested this yet obviously I
haven't on it so we'll have to UM see if
this actually works but that is the idea
okay
it's not easy to grasp right straight
away but if you work through logically
and do some a nice hand execution you
will see so first of all do we move and
yeah we do and we seem to be moving at
the same rate and everything as last
time which is fantastic now let's let's
just hop into player here quickly and
first thing I'll do actually is I'll
make a quick variable here called speed
I'll actually make it a double and we'll
go ahead and try something like one just
to see how fast that feels before I go
into decimal so we'll go
- tickle Speedway applause nicholas
pearce what I'm doing is I'm just
switching out this to for a variable so
that if I want to change the speed I can
just do it in one place rather than
having to update it in four locations
here so I'll launch this beast and women
this is okay this is what one feels like
so now let's have that let's just drop
to zero point five let's see what that
feels like and see if it even works okay
at the moment it does not work you can
see that we're not moving that is
obviously an issue so the best way to
troubleshoot this right now would be to
actually get rid of any other entity
because what happens is if we are if we
want to move then we can't actually like
all the Bridget all the sorry all the
arms what are they called all the mobs
that we've created in our spawn level
all these chases that we have that we've
added they also use the method so it
will be able won't be able to check
properly so now that we've isolated it
let's go ahead and go into mob and we
can simply print out something like this
dot X to the console right and just for
the posters of this I'll actually just
drag my console up here so that you guys
can see it and we'll check that out so
as we move here okay we actually didn't
get anything right now which is weird
this is getting oh right hang on this is
very simple explanation of this probably
and that is okay actually hang on a
minute why I and X a are integers okay
so we're fading in inches is so let's
change that to a double and now let's
see how this role they'll bring up the
console as well as you guys can see here
and look at that we're moving at half
speed and if you over here and you look
at the console you can see that we're
getting values if I just terminate this
we're getting values like two hundred
eighty one point five now two hundred
eighty 1.0 two eighty point five to
eighty point zero than just getting 81
80 79 78 etc so we've had a lot more
precision you can feel it we're moving a
lot slower if I wants to change the
speed to zero point one let's go back to
mom here and what we'll do is we'll
actually um we will get rid of this
print line statement and if I go into
will go into level spawn level here and
we'll get
our mops now that we've fixed this so
it's zero point one right now let's see
us like we move here and while look at
that
we're basically lagging because we're
moving so slowly but you can see how
that's working alright so that is
literally this loss that we can move
well we move a little slower obviously
now we should also be able to move at
about so let's just see what one feels
like and now let's jump to like one
point four and yeah that's definitely
faster but not as fast as - right - or
two point four here's a lot faster so
now that we've done this let's do the
ultimate thing that we kind of
implemented this for and that is those
chasers they are if we go back to if we
go to the chase to the chaser class we
had these let's make a speed for the
chaser here we'll put it up as a at the
top here as a global variable for this
class we'll set it to zero point eight
so now we should be able to outrun them
which is slightly right and we'll make
sure that this is a double so we'll grab
speed here and we'll go plus equal speed
- equals speed while single speed and -
equals speed okay and the other thing
you have to make sure of course is that
X a and Y a are indeed doubles not
integers so double and double and that
we're fitting it into the move method
which we are brilliant so let's take a
look at that so if we go to the chaser
let's actually yeah okay this is the
change that he'll chase us but you can
see we can outrun him look at that just
slightly outrun him look at that works
barely making it there we go and then he
stopped chasing us all right isn't that
awesome running running running running
running but you can see we're moving
just just a touch
faster than him and there he goes he
stops okay so that is the end of this
episode wow what an episode
okay we're probably going to start on if
I don't think of anything else but
probably will will some of the a-star
search algorithm soon so that'll enable
our our um and wants to actually find
paths to us through walls so I'll be
able to have the intelligence to walk
around the wall rather than bump into
and not go anywhere but apart from that
if you guys did enjoy the video please
the like button three hundred likes and
I'll post a video tomorrow okay exam
times coming up so I'm a bit strain on
time but again if enough of you want
this then
absolutely happy to make it for you so
300 likes equals a video tomorrow if not
I'll probably maybe wait a day or two
just because um I've got a lot of study
on my on my hands but again you know
I'll make more time if you guys so want
it but anyway
again I hope you enjoyed this awesome
game programming video and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
you